and we have the Dunkin eggs stories
actually we did after this book my next
book will be next spring and it'll be
called the night of the seven kingdoms
and it is a collection of the three
published Dunkin egg novellas the hedge
knight is sworn sword in the mystery
Knight but illustrated by Gary Johnny
and Gary did ice and fire calendar a
couple years ago he's he's done Prince
Valiant for years he did the wandering
star books for bran Mac Morin and
Solomon Kane gorgeous books if you don't
have those and your buddy Howard fan
some beautiful books I've ever seen and
you know Johnny looks like NC Wyeth
returned from the dead and some of his
work is just amazing artists so we
wanted him to illustrate the duncan egg
collection and you know our thought was
well do a couple color pieces and then
like seven or eight interior
illustrations that you can do and he
read them and and fell in love with them
and got back I said well I'll do it but
I don't want to do that what I want to
do is like a picture for every page and
just have this thing absolutely loaded
with gorgeous art and so that's what
he's been working on for the last year
and a half or so so when that comes out
that's gonna be amazing
illustrated book the night of the Seven
Kingdoms be sure to get the hardcover
that one will be worth well worth it